foreign
[Music]
thank you all for joining us my name is
Wyatt Gorman I'm the high performance
Computing Solutions manager here at
Google Cloud today presenting with me I
have Annie hi everyone I'm Annie ma
Weaver I'm the product manager for high
performance Computing and I'm really
excited to be here
awesome so we have a few topics for you
today we're going to level set first of
all about what HPC is and why it's
important to several Industries second
how we're helping HPC customers thrive
on Google Cloud third what we're doing
to advance the HP state-of-the-art HPC
state-of-the-art excuse me on Google
cloud and then finally how you can go
and deploy your own HPC environments end
to end on Google
so to get started let's talk about what
HPC is and why it's so important for so
many different Industries
so organizations across many different
Industries are really facing a
tremendous growth of data and demand to
process that data right this is just a
few Industries uh but you know you've
seen advances in medicine recently that
mean more new drugs are coming to Market
every year and in fact the FDA is
approving more new drugs each year and
since 2010 than they had in any previous
decade so you know do you see it in drug
Discovery you see it in genomics you see
it in brain simulations and Health Care
life sciences and financial services you
know the the variable markets that we've
been seeing over maybe the last few
years combined with increased regulatory
requirements and compliance requirements
has really driven the financial
institutions that we rely on to
re-examine the the tools and the
mechanisms they have to process that
data right to do things like Risk
analysis and then manufacturing
Industries are really struggling to put
data to use in production right most uh
in a lot of Industries I should say have
manufacturing Industries have found that
they they can't really use data at scale
in their manufacturing and this you know
obviously doesn't cover public sector or
media entertainment retail or a number
of other Industries where HPC is is
growing very very quickly to to meet the
demands of you know all of these factors
so
um why are people looking at HPC right
HPC offers Business Leaders the
opportunity to speed up the processing
of the Deluge of data that they're
seeing and to get the results that
they're looking for faster while still
controlling costs right we were just in
a meeting uh where I heard yet again
I've heard this from so many customers
that they had a decision to make at some
point between building out an
on-premises HPC infrastructure to solve
one of their tasks this was a financial
services industry to so to do the risk
analysis that they needed for the
Regulatory Compliance it would have cost
about 20 million dollars to build out an
HPC system that would have lasted them
you know maybe five or seven years but
would have done the task on the other
hand they could run that in a and Google
Cloud's HPC for half a million dollars a
year right so that kind of decision is
easy to make when that's the the
mathematics that you're looking at right
um so you know scalability HPC does does
what it does by scaling workloads across
multiple resources by scaling up and out
and distributing that work then across
all of those resources and parallelizing
that work to speed up the work being
done while maintaining costs
however the the idea of implementing HPC
on-premises has its limitations right
this is what people have been doing for
years and we've really hit the the
limits um I think the the systems that
people design for HPC systems are built
in fixed amounts right so you decide at
some point you want 100 000 cores 10 000
cores whatever it is however many gpus
and that's the system that you go and
procure and install and it takes you
know up to a year to go through the the
process of you know putting out an RFP
if you do that talking with vendors
architecting your system getting it
built and and shipped and then doing
acceptance testing right some of the
really large systems take a long long
time to to get approved and they're
built on this multi-year refresh
schedule right so you have every five or
seven years you can look at a new set of
Hardware whereas you might already be
two or three generations out of date on
the latest gpus for example and users in
a shared system typically wait behind
other users multiple other users in a
queue right for access to those
resources because it's you know it's
very expensive to build out an HPC
system to handle all the work that you
might possibly need that that system to
do right and we'll talk about a couple
users and and why they how they've seen
that
um but you know waiting behind other
users limits the amount of work you can
do limits time to Innovation time to
results for manufacturing right and in
Industries where you're trying to come
to Market with something first
that can be devastating right not being
able to to get your results in the time
that you need
um and when organizations look at
migrating their workloads to the cloud
it gets sometimes even more paralyzing
right the amount of uh work that you
need to do to move to the cloud the
potential cost not just of the move but
of re-platforming any tools and training
users can be daunting right can seem
intimidating
luckily for everyone here and everyone
else Google cloud has an HPC platform
that has a full spectrum of easy to use
products tools and Integrations for you
to run your HPC workloads really really
easily and cost efficiently on Google
Cloud
so that includes our infrastructure
first on the left with the latest
processors and accelerators reliability
and security built in high performance
storage options which we'll talk a
little bit more about and high
throughput low latency networking
between VMS
on top of that we layer our platform
right our HPC tools and services this
covers things like our simple batch
service which is our managed scheduler
for simple batch workloads that covers
the Google kubernetes engine that we
have for containerized workloads and
we'll talk a little bit about how that's
come up to speed for HPC and it's not
just a web serving platform anymore and
it includes our Cloud HPC toolkit which
we'll talk about more as well and
finally we support a broad partner
ecosystem of Partners across isvs system
providers system software providers so
like schedulers and storage and then
system integrators as well to make sure
that customers can bring the the
software that they're used to to Google
Cloud without the need to re-platform if
it doesn't make sense and that they have
the partners there to help them
Implement that
so how have we helped users of Google
Cloud HPC platform actually thrive on
Google Cloud right to answer that
question I want to look at three
Industries and three different stories
from those Industries
so first is higher education right
Academia the University of California is
a great example excuse me the University
of California Riverside is a great
example where researchers were facing
the the very common challenge in HPC of
high demand for limited resources right
I mentioned queuing uh behind other
users and that's that's exactly what
they face they also face the challenge
of a traditional academic research
environment where multiple researchers
have multiple interests multiple jobs
and you can never really tell how much
anyone's going to need at any one time
or when they're going to need it right
they might just show up you might get a
new pi and this happens all the time
where people bring in a new principal
investigator and they get a lot of money
and they need a lot of compute all of a
sudden right so what UC Riverside did
was they combined two key components to
solve this issue first is the cloud HPC
toolkit which we'll talk about a little
bit later and second is the Google Cloud
public sector subscription agreement so
the public sector subscription agreement
is a fixed cost subscription model for
public sector users who are running HPC
workloads and it's specifically built to
address the bursty needs of HPC
workloads right again you can never
really tell if somebody's going to log
in on the weekend and spin up a large
job or something like that so you have
to be ready right to to flex and to
respond to customers needs and that's
really the point of the cloud of course
but the cost variability associated with
that can be challenging right often in
academic environments they're working on
fixed grants or you know multi-year
budget timelines and they can't just
Flex that cost so the public sector
subscription agreements gives them a
fixed cost where you can even go above
the predetermined amount of resources
that you get with your commitment and we
won't charge you extra for that so it's
especially built for HPC users in the
public sector industry
um do you see the CIO of UC Riverside
has even said that by combining the
public sector subscription agreement and
the Google Cloud HPC toolkit they're
able to offer their researchers
opportunities that they would not get
outside of UC Riverside and without this
technology so we're really proud of that
computer-aided engineering is another
very heavyweight workload in HPC right
and it covers multiple uh different
workloads computer computational fluid
dynamics Structural Engineering all
these sorts of things you might be a
little more familiar with
um and it's it's a workload where the
HPC worked on can directly impact the
time to market for a company right think
about your pixel phone or you know your
car right doing the the drop simulations
and the crash simulations and making
sure that it's safe where it's not going
to crack it's important to before going
to Market so being able to do those
simulations faster than anyone else is
is important when you're in a time
crunch
so what we did was uh we partnered with
a number of isvs but Altera is one of
the key isvs in the CAE space and we ran
some benchmarks with them on our latest
and greatest H3 VMS which Annie will
talk about more and they found that they
were able to speed up the simulation
runtimes of one of their most popular
CIA applications radios by up to 3x
versus the last generation of HPC VM
types so that kind of performance
Improvement for Altair's customers
really makes a difference in terms of
you know being able to do work right if
a engineer had to wait a day to get a
simulation done now they can do three in
a day right that's the kind of
difference that we're talking about here
um and then finally drug Discovery is uh
you know tremendously computationally
complex workload in HPC uh it requires
vast amounts of data and a significant
number of iterations over that data in
order to do the kind of drug Discovery
uh and and chemical Library sort of
screening that they need to do and
Schrodinger is is one of our customers
they've been a customer of ours for a
long time but they found the HPC
platform at Google Cloud as as a perfect
source of that computing power that they
need and they've been able to explore
more chemical compounds using Google
Cloud than they ever have been before so
you know opening up the the scale and
the scope of what customers can do in
their own industries by offering them
more and better HPC resources is is
really our goal and they found that you
know the request to Google Cloud to spin
up tens of thousands of gpus wasn't an
issue and that really really helped them
do their work
so to now they understand you know what
our customers are doing today and how
they're thriving I'm going to hand it
over to Annie to dive into how we're
advancing the state of the art with HPC
on Google Cloud great
hi everyone I am delighted to tell you
about our CPUs gpus and storage product
announcements and the reason we find
this exciting is that it will help our
HPC customers more easily deploy Google
Cloud resources to start solving our
problems at scale in a cost performance
manner
our hpsc platform consists of three
layers of cloud infrastructure
deployment and development Cloud
infrastructure compute storage
networking you know it you love it I'm
going to tell you more about it
development includes our built-in
development tools including our
communication libraries like nickel and
MPI
our infrastructure management tooling
finally there's deployment which
includes amazing products like the cloud
HBC toolkit the hvcvm image and batch
we coordinate offerings across compute
networking storage and work with
partners and open source projects to
develop end-to-end solutions for your
hvc needs
this is a gorgeous slide I recommend you
I see some people taking pictures please
do it's very nice
I like to share some new compute engine
virtual machines that are built for HBC
first Google compute engine or GCE
provides VM families to suit your
workload needs whether they are more
general purpose or Mission critical
highly performance intensive
our C3 machine series is now generally
available
these are built on the Intel fourth
generation sign let's see if I can say
the scalable processor codenamed
Sapphire Rapids and are available for
our GCE and gke customers
to further support our customers and
Advance our commitment to workload
optimized infrastructure we are
launching our new H3 virtual machine
Series so we actually launched this a
couple weeks ago and I wanted to see by
a show of hands have you guys heard of
this before
okay all right okay for those who raise
their hands please come up and you can
talk more about it
okay so the H3 series is our first
machine series that is optimized for HPC
it is again built on Sapphire Rapids and
takes advantage of our Google Cloud
custom Intel infrastructure Processing
Unit or ipu
the H3 is an addition to our compute
optimized VM family which includes the
C2 and c2ds
H3 has shown performance improvements
over prior generation c2s for a number
of key HBC use cases including molecular
Dynamics Eda weather forecasting and
more
the h3s offer 200 gigabyte per second
default low latency networking which is
two times the prior generation
it also offers up to three times
Improvement in per node performance
again compared to the c2s and we're not
knocking the c2s they are phenomenal but
the h3s are truly a step forward
we also have seen two times better price
performance versus the c2s and we've
worked with leading Partners like Altair
ansys parallel Works to create the best
experience for HPC customers and I know
why I just talked about some of those
benchmarks that we ran with Altair
next I want to talk to you about
something that is in the news I'm sure
you've heard you're probably sick of
hearing about it but AIML what are we
doing there
so we have the A3 supercomputers which
will be generally available next month
and these supercomputers are
purpose-built to train and serve the
most advanced machine learning models
and these models they are powering
today's generative Ai and large language
modeling Innovation I'm sure at this
point you've heard about gen Ai and llm
so many times that it could be a
drinking game
have
here are some key features of the a3s
they are powered on eight Hopper 100
Nvidia gpus and they show up to three
times higher performance for AI training
versus the prior generation a2s as well
as 10 times Network
10 times Network bandwidth increase
the Nvidia Collective Communications
library or nickel is built for deep
learning Frameworks like tensorflow and
pytorch and is used for multi-node and
multi-gpu training
fast socket is a Google proprietary
Network transport built for nickel and
we've seen an increase in net bandwidth
speeds using fast socket because of its
ability to decrease contention between
multiple TCP connections
in fact we've seen up to 60 Improvement
in all reduced throughput
for those interested in setting up a
fast socket environment you can either
use a deep learning VM image or a
compute engine Public Image
compacts placement reduces latency by
placing nodes in closer proximity and is
well suited for tightly coupled batch
workloads it can be specified at the
node pool or cluster level
the cued resource manager or qrm is a
way for customers to request VM
instances of scarce resources like gpus
once you have put in your request you'll
get either a high confidence response
about whether your request can be
fulfilled and by when or an immediate
response that your request cannot be
fulfilled
this way you can better manage your
capacity demands
next I'm excited to share an Innovative
addition to our storage portfolio for
HPC
but first we have the right storage for
your processing type
either through our native offerings or
partner Integrations
moving and storing your data on Google
cloud is quick and easy
as I like to say to my four-year-old you
take care of The Logical that Mama worry
about the physical
it does not land that well with her
I am so pleased to announce the launch
of our first party parallel file system
parallel store built on the Intel Davis
storage stack
and for those on the live stream which I
know you are there I want to say thank
you so much to the parallel store
engineering team you guys did such great
work we're really proud of you
parallel store is semi-scrash with a GCS
durable layer and it will be used to
accelerate high performance applications
that require both High scale and low
latency data access
I want to share with you some Benchmark
results
in particular I want to highlight the
sub millisecond latency and the read
throughput of up to three 6.3 times of
AWS FSX for luster scratch Baseline I
also want to highlight the high MD Ops
which helps support
emerging i o patterns and also AIML
patterns
parallel store is now available in
private preview which means that if
you're interested in using it please let
us know so that we can make sure that
you have access
and actually on that note I'm going to
go back a couple slides to H3 because
I've forgot to emphasize the most
important thing which is that it is now
available in public preview which means
if you want to access it today you can
find it in the cloud console but if you
want to start testing please let us know
so we can provision you adequate
capacity
and public preview means that it's free
of charge for you to use
now I want to tell you about some ways
that you can deploy HPC resources on
Google Cloud
of course you can build it from scratch
yourself and I know many of you are
capable of doing that but we also
recommend that you consider some of the
tools here
for those who want to quickly customize
and deploy an hvc environment with
partner Integrations built in we have
the cloud hvc toolkit which I will go
into more detail about shortly
gke is ideal if you want a platform to
manage or containerize applications it
gives you the operational power of
kubernetes while maintaining and
managing a lot of the underlying
components like control plane and nodes
for you
last but not least Google Cloud batch it
is a first party Cloud native fully
integrated batch scheduler so that you
can schedule queue and execute resources
for your batch processing workloads
products
toolkit
the cloud HPC toolkit is a modular
composable collection of resources
written in terraform to help you quickly
and easily deploy repeatable TurnKey
environments that have the Google Cloud
hvc best practices built in
the toolkit has three key components
first blueprints which is exactly what
it sounds like the design for your HPC
system
blueprints can be general purpose
workload specific or built around a
partner solution
lucky for you the toolkit comes with a
number of example blueprints which you
can use to customize or give you
inspiration for building something anew
the blueprints and reference modules of
the toolkit supports
modules break down into categories like
storage and schedulers
and the modular modules then Deploy on
Google infrastructure to start running
your HBC systems
all right here is an example blueprint
or yaml file with about 60 lines of code
give you a moment to take that in
this is actually what it looks like I
know everyone is shocked
the blueprint is then used to create a
deployment artifact which is a folder
that has about three or four thousand
lines of code
and that deployment artifact is then
used to deploy an HBC system which can
be forty thousand five plus lines of
code so for those who are doing the math
you go from a simple yaml file of about
60 lines all the way up to 40 000 plus
lines of Deployable code but you don't
have to write it and that's where
toolkit simplifies things
setting up your HPC cluster if you had
to write all that code yourself would
have taken days and weeks but now with
the toolkit you can get that up and
running in minutes and hours
now I'm going to turn it back over to
Wyatt who's going to tell you about some
other ways to deploy hvc systems gke and
batch
thanks Annie yeah
so
um just a reminder before I jump into
gke and batch that the cloud HPC toolkit
is not only capable of deploying Google
compute engine resources like the slurm
cluster blueprint you saw earlier but
it's also able to deploy Google
kubernetes engine resources batch
resources or a number of other resources
single VM dashboards in our op Suite
there's a there's a number of modules
that make it really easy to build an
entire end-to-end HPC environment
regardless of the the software stack
that you're using uh so Google
kubernetes engine is a really great
option for running any of your HPC
workloads or AI workloads for that
matter that are containerized right it's
not the only option you can definitely
run containers on VMS and that gives you
a little bit more flexibility but gke is
is really great for eliminating the need
to worry about the infrastructure layer
the security the maintenance any of that
right
we've done a lot of work on gke recently
I think most people are familiar with
kubernetes as a web hosting platform and
you know in complete honesty that's
definitely what it was until recently
we've done a lot of work over the last
year year and a half or so to implement
a number of features that I'll describe
that really change the the way you
should look at kubernetes and think
about kubernetes
uh in regards to HPC so um this includes
features like Q so Q is actually a
contribution back to the kubernetes open
source but Q implements the basic
concepts that we're familiar with in HPC
of jobs job scheduling job priorities
and dependencies and job cues so it
allows users to fair share capacity
between gke nodes and node pools and it
lets you implement the things you're
used to in HPC environments like job
policies per user or per job like I
mentioned priorities and and other
similar capabilities that you would
expect out of basically any HPC job
scheduler
sharing uh at optimizing gpus on GK is
another feature that we've introduced to
help optimize the performance of HPC and
AI workloads as well as the the
utilization right utilization is a very
important thing in HPC
um and so making sure that you're not
leaving you know Cycles on the table is
is really important so we added you know
features like nvidia's multi-instance
gpus that lets you split out a GPU
across multiple instances
multi-process service time sharing
between gpus and that all allows you to
split up and share gpus better across
multiple jobs or multiple users
and just make more efficient use of
especially the really large gpus that
we're starting to see more and more of
today
um
then there's also uh nickel nickel fast
socket and Annie described what nickel
is so I won't get into the details but
um nickel fast socket basically allows
you to accelerate those distributed
operations like all Reduce by up to
about 60 in some cases and that's really
important I'm sure you're familiar with
HPC use cases but also more and more
distributed AI training use cases which
oftentimes use a lot of traditional HPC
technology
um nickel fast socket works better than
any that better than ever in a compact
placement policy right so you saw
compact placements earlier that works
for Google compute engine as well as
Google kubernetes engine
um and then qrm is also supported in
acute Resource Management excuse me it's
also supported in gke to allow you to
ensure that you can have access to the
GPU resources on a compact placement
policy and make efficient use of them
when you need them right and you're not
you know maybe looking around for
capacity or waiting for capacity
GK has also expanded a number the number
of VMS and nodes that they support in a
pool so they actually have 3x the number
of 15 000 nodes in a cluster so three
times what other managed kubernetes
Services provide or or allow you to
scale up to
um and you know that's really important
for customers like bear who are able to
run 15 billion genotypes per hour now
that they've been able to scale up to
this you know crazy level in gke but
it's also important for customers like
pgs uh who are not only able to migrate
off of their on-premises traditional
cray based supercomputer environment
right cray is one of the oldest running
HPC providers and system providers in
the world
um and so they moved off of their cray
and luster file system environment to
Google cloud and then they moved to GK a
gke based environment and with Google
Cloud Storage instead of a parallel file
system
and in doing so they built what could be
a system that Rivals the top systems in
the world right so there's this top 500
list and so pgs built themselves a gke
based supercomputer that uh you know
really put gke to the tests and it was
awesome to see they passed 2.8 million
vcpus in a single environment 180
000 gke nodes and if they benchmarked
that with the standard HPC Benchmark
called linpak they would have reached
about 72 petaflops of computing power
that would have placed them at the top
seven the number seven top supercomputer
in the world at the time if they had
actually taken the time to Benchmark it
and you know weren't using it for more
important things
um but you know that just goes to
demonstrate the the scalability and the
remarkable power that gke has now and
that it's not just a web hosting
platform anymore
foreign
batch is another great solution for HPC
workloads especially where your primary
goal is getting your work done as
quickly as possible without having to
worry about anything else
so I I say that because batch is our
fully managed zero Ops scheduling
service built for and by Google
um so the the Zero apps part is
important so it's really designed for
users to really easily run their HPC
workloads out of the box without needing
to understand the complexities of a
traditional scheduler environment right
have to worry about data too much and
without additional complexity or cost
right this is a free service on top of
the resources that you use and it's
um you know something that supports
containers you could use it without
containers and supports all of our HPC
storage options it's also very tightly
integrated as you can see with a lot of
our first party and third-party workflow
engines so you can use it with all of
our tools like the toolkit with our
workflows and our scheduler composer
will be supported very shortly as well
next month
um and almost more importantly is the
Integrations with the third party
workflow managers so
um for anybody who's in the healthcare
and Life Sciences industry you might be
familiar with the next flow workflow
manager that is basically one of the
most popular workflow managers in
um really genomics processing but
Healthcare and Life Sciences in general
and so we've built a really tight
integration with next flow where users
of nextflow can actually deploy directly
to batch just point next flow to batch
as their endpoint and without having to
even interact with batch or send you
know configure anything in batch they
can just go and deploy a job directly
from next flow so that's the kind of
ease and simplicity we're looking to
drive with with batch where Cloud HPC
toolkit lets you get in you know line by
line and edit things and run scripts and
configure tuning and you know maximum
configurability batch is as simple as it
can get right so if you have you know
researchers or people who are just
looking to get their science done who
aren't too concerned about the computer
science batches where you should send
them there are many ways to build job
definitions so we support uh everything
from simple Json at the uh you know most
uh fundamental level all the way through
to a web-based cloud console where you
can go and click through and you know
understand what your options are without
having to read through some manuals or
whatnot and moreover jobs can really be
easily visualized in the cloud console
there you can see the top image which
I'm sorry is cut off has a listing of
jobs there and so you can really easily
easily monitor jobs and you know batch
will make sure that your jobs run it'll
re-cue jobs if there are issues support
spot and all of the features that you
would expect batch to to support out of
the box and you know despite how simple
it is uh it's really a feature-rich HPC
scheduler right so it supports all the
features you'd expect
um supports you know high throughput
jobs or HTC jobs it supports tightly
coupled jobs like MPI it supports job
retries and priorities custom VM images
which can be really important for a lot
of folks you know Regional placement
policy which is key in bulk API compact
placement qrm all of these sorts of
things that I that we have talked about
throughout the the talk as well as a
number of our HPC storage options and
the the CSI driver for uh parallel store
will be coming shortly as well I'm sorry
the CSI driver for gke will be coming
shortly
um
so
yeah
all this work is really part of the HPC
strategy that we have overall and that's
been guiding our work for the last
several years
um and so that's really broken down into
four key pillars first is fast and
affordable speaks to the infrastructure
right the the new H3 and A3 VMS the
actual infrastructure that we build
parallel store and our networking
and making sure that all of those
components work really well for HPC
workloads right so that the the CPU
works well with the networking and can
run MPI applications as quickly as
possible
um and then that gets into easy and
compatible so that's about our platform
making sure that you know I mentioned
things like our bulk API that allow you
to spin up a thousand VMS per API call
those kinds of features that allow you
to to do the HPC things that you need to
do efficiently
um are what we're aiming to do with our
easy and compatible as well as being
compatible with the leading application
providers and schedulers and system
software providers and so that gets into
partner preferred we really want if you
go to one of your partners and say Hey
you know we're looking at moving to the
cloud who would you recommend we want
them to say Google first right so we're
working with as many partners as we can
to ensure that their applications are
benchmarked and are qualified and
compatible with Google cloud and that if
whenever possible they perform better
than other Cloud providers and
on-premises so you'll see more
competitive benchmarks from us soon that
also goes for the schedulers and the
storage as well as the system
integrators right the folks who you'll
bring in to actually help you implement
these workloads and then finally it's
about uh you know bringing the best of
Google so that's our industry expertise
we've had customers where we've brought
the folks who are building the alpha
fold ml models or the Deep variant
models we bring them into the
conversation right we have Eda customers
where we bring the folks who are
designing our TPU chips to them and say
you know share how you run on Google
cloud with with our customer so that
kind of industry expertise we definitely
want to bring to you and and make sure
that you can learn from us and that we
learn from you at the same time leading
ML and data analytics tools you know um
just a a brief idea of this you can dump
all of your job scheduler logs into
bigquery and then you can use bigquery
ml to understand you know how a user is
running their jobs when they most
frequently run their jobs what the
average cost is so these are the kinds
of ways we're looking to integrate trade
ML and data analytics into our HPC
environment right top to bottom and then
you know making sure that the technology
that we bring to bear whether it's our
worldwide Network or kubernetes or other
things really works well for HPC and so
you know one of my favorite examples is
the uh the lsst project or it's called
now the virusy Reuben Observatory it's
the largest telescope in the world it's
built on a mountain in Chile and they
process 20 terabytes of astronomical
data at night over the Google Cloud
Network off the mountain in Chile over
our worldwide distributed Network up to
the U.S central zone where it's
processed and then distributed out
around the world for researchers to
examine so that kind of scientific
workload where you need to Transit data
you know halfway across the world
overnight and then distribute it around
the rest of the world is where things
like our worldwide Network come into
play
so with that I really hope that you
enjoyed our talk today we really hope
you enjoy the rest of the week and we
hope you're able to attend some of our
other talks that are related to HPC and
AIML workloads and please go see our
partners we've got a number of great
Partners down there in the in the
Showcase and definitely go visit those
puppies I'm gonna I'm gonna go down
there right now
uh oh and uh we really appreciate
feedback here at Google uh hopefully you
all realize that we we really actually
like if you submit a bug somebody sees
it and I've I've plus one and and echoed
bugs that you know have come in from the
outside so please please please give us
feedback that not only goes for bugs
with our products but also for our
sessions so um if you have a minute
please go ahead and get feedback in the
app we'd really appreciate it and with
that I want to thank you all so much and
say enjoy the rest of the week
[Applause]